well now to a story that broke just last
night a teenager shot and killed at an
apartment complex in North Las Vegas
tonight parents who live nearby sharing
what they heard and revealing how their
neighborhood has become a breeding
ground for trouble in these past couple
of months eight news now reporter
Madison Kimbrough was there today and
has the story
it's the end of the school year which
means summer vacation and grad parties
but unfortunately for one teen a house
party turned fatal when he was shot and
killed Sunday night there's always
trouble in this complex the police are
always here especially in that area
where that kid was shot at a tragic
situation Sunday night as a 14 year old
boy was shot and killed at the Craig
Ranch Villas Apartment Complex in North
Las Vegas one neighbor who wasn't
comfortable showing her face on camera
recalls what she heard shortly before 10
pm as far as I know they were having
some sort of party around the corner I
believe it was a graduation party and
next thing you know gunfire going off
and car speeding out of here and then I
guess there were some teenage girls that
were walking by and they were screaming
and hollering I can't believe they did
that parents in the neighborhood
frightened for their own families admit
this apartment complex has been going
downhill fast with a list of recent
problems considering I am a mother of of
two younger children around here it
makes me reconsider even being
in this location recently there has been
different things like yes the different
animal attacks another robbery that
actually happened over here
and now this one with a child being shot
North Las Vegas Police have yet to
confirm who they may be searching for or
if the person responsible for the
child's death is already in custody as
for the identity of the child the
coroner's office has yet to release that
information and it's still unclear if
the boy died on scene or was taken to a
nearby hospital in North Las Vegas
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now